vivimos en el momento histórico de la
contradicción la contradicción de yo te
escucho pero solo para responderte de
ello te respeto pero si piensas lo mismo
que yo en ser la sociedad más preparada
de la historia y que cada vez más
triunfen más las políticas autoritarias
de tener los recursos alimentarios para
una dieta saludable y que cada vez haya
más casos de obesidad o de tener los
medios para estar conectados y en red
con otras personas y sentirnos más solos
que nunca vivimos en el ya en el corre
en el ahora en un paradigma de la
inmediatez por lo que no es de extrañar
que ocurran todas estas cosas ya que no
tenemos ni tiempo ni espacio para
cuidarnos y reflexionar
hemos vendido nuestro tiempo y si no lo
has hecho siempre con la mejor de las
fortunas y productividad falta de
paciencia falta de esos espacios y
tiempos de cuidado nos convierten en una
sociedad que está enferma y que nos hace
enfermar por eso necesitamos un cambio
pero ha sido esto siempre así no tenemos
que retroceder y por un lado irnos a la
revolución industrial siglo 19 aquí se
produce un incremento de la
productividad del trabajo y de la
producción de la riqueza mucho dinero en
poco tiempo collazo total y también nos
tenemos que ubicar
en la generación del 60 aquí se produce
una ruptura en los roles y las normas
está generación da paso a la libertad
como es la liberación sexual y al placer
a través del sexo y las drogas
esta generación da un paso de la espera
a la inmediatez del ahorro al gasto y
del largo plazo a la inexistencia de
este si volvemos otra vez a la
actualidad nos encontramos con esa
productividad con esa inmediatez con ese
don ismo y le tenemos que sumar el
neoliberalismo ahora todos somos
mercancías para dar y obtener beneficio
el tiempo se nos ha esfumado y vamos a
todos lados con prisa porque queremos
obtener las cosas ya
el filósofo surcoreano hyun fulham diría
que hoy en día nos explotamos a nosotros
mismos y decimos que nos estamos
realizando y es que hoy en día nos
sentimos orgullosos de no tener tiempo
nos quejamos nos quejamos muchísimo pero
nos sentimos importante y es que hoy en
día no tener tiempo de cuidarte y de
descansar te convierte en alguien
importante que se está realizando el
problema de esto es que no se queda solo
a nivel individual sino que se ha
trasladado y hace incidencia a los
objetos a la alimentación a la
naturaleza y también a las relaciones
objetos de un solo uso programados para
no durar obsolescencia programada
así los tiras y compras uno nuevo sin
necesidad de desarrollar valores como el
cuidado y la reparación
obesidad a la orden del día según el
estudio del 2017 de la revista the
lancet el 25 por ciento de la población
española sufre de obesidad o sobrepeso
somos el segundo país de europa por con
más casos de obesidad por detrás de
reino unido pero nosotros no éramos los
de la dieta mediterránea y es que no
tenemos tiempo y como no tenemos tiempo
vamos al súper y compramos productos
ultra procesados o precocinados a
expensas de nuestra salud en cuanto a la
naturaleza solo y ver hay que ver cómo
se encuentra hoy en día y este 2020 tan
ajetreado que tenemos pero no hay
problema
vosotros seguir usando las cápsulas del
café en vez de la cafetera tradicional
porque es mejor no malgastar el tiempo
que malgastar recursos como todo tiene
solución pues también lo tiene no
encontrar pareja
ahora se trata de consumirlas hasta que
te aburres y pasas a otra ya no hay unos
cimientos sobre los que crear sobre los
que compartir sobre los que aceptar que
la otra persona no es perfecta y que
toda relación requiere de trabajo como
tenemos ni tiempo ni paciencia ahora
cubrimos la necesidad físico sexual y
hasta luego mari carmen y debe ser que
esto de la paciencia no es tan nuevo ya
que el filósofo alemán del siglo 18
kant cuya pronunciación es mucho más
sencilla nos decía que la paciencia es
la fortaleza del débil y la impaciencia
la debilidad del fuerte
entenderíamos hoy en día al débil como
aquella persona mediocre y aquí me
permito hacer un inciso ya que cada vez
se utiliza más la palabra mediocre en
término despectivo y todos somos
mediocres porque formamos parte de la
media o inferior en muchísimas cosas así
que lo siento
siento despertarlos de vuestros sueños
de la perfección pero todos somos
mediocres cerrando este inciso vuelvo
esa persona
débil considerada mediocre un agente
pasivo que no lucha por sus sueños
en contraposición de ese ser fuerte que
no tiene tiempo ni para respirar pero
que se está realizando esto
lo que nos sitúa es que no estamos
desarrollando la paciencia tan necesaria
para gestionar la frustración la
ansiedad el estrés este trío nada
placentero me lo encontrado a veces
también acompañado de la depresión y me
lo he encontrado en muchos ámbitos en la
clínica por supuesto pero también cuando
estaba trabajando en la universidad en
las aulas y en los despachos en chavales
súper jóvenes de los institutos y
también en mi vida y en la vida de las
personas a las que quiero por eso no os
recomiendo nada este trío probar otro
tipo de tríos comida variada deporte
relaciones de calidad yo no sé qué tipo
de trío estabais pensando no es
casualidad que cada vez haya más
problemas de salud mental relacionados
con la ansiedad y la depresión
según datos de la organización mundial
de la salud en 2005 los problemas de
ansiedad pasaron de un 15,1 a un 21,1 en
datos también de la oms nos indican que
entre los 10 y 19 años la primera y
quinta causa de pérdida de años de vida
saludable eran la depresión y las auto
flexiones pero es que no se queda sólo
ahí sino que también
en el 2016 salieron datos de que la
segunda causa de muerte en el mundo
entre los 15 y 29 años e insisto 15 y 29
años era el suicidio no estamos dando
estrategias para afrontar nos a este
mundo
y claro como no estamos dando estas
estrategias nos encontramos con la
muerte a nivel físico hipertensión
anemia dolores de cabeza también la
muerte a nivel psicológico irritabilidad
desmotivación frustración y la muerte a
nivel relacional problemas en casa en el
trabajo económicos en el mejor de los
casos se quiere buscar una solución pero
como no podía ser de otra manera es la
solución rápida la pastilla arregla todo
la pastilla para el sueño la pastilla
para los problemas digestivos la
pastilla para la tristeza tenemos tan
poco tiempo de encargarnos de nosotros
mismos estamos patologizante la vida y
no es sólo eso es que hoy en día también
se ha mercantilizado la salud en los
últimos diez años ha crecido de manera
exponencial el consumo de psicofármacos
ansiolíticos antidepresivos hipnóticos
per se esto lo que nos dice es que ha
habido un aumento de los problemas de
salud mental pero esto es sólo la punta
del iceberg hay muchos problemas de
transfondo con esto no digo que no sea
necesario utilizar pastillas es la
solución a corto plazo y en muchos casos
necesaria pero no soluciona el problema
de base y para ello a veces es necesario
ir a terapia la terapia normalmente se
centra en el ser y la sociedad nos
empuja a tener hacer y estar en todas
partes y me da especialmente coraje
porque en español distinguimos entre ser
y estar y no dedicamos tiempo a ser a
ser personas que no máquinas le pese a
quien le pese
en esta línea victor frank en el libro
de el hombre en busca de sentido nos
indica que es mucho más importante
buscar el sentido del ser frente al
placer sin embargo estamos tan obcecados
en obtener ese placer inmediato que nos
perdemos a nosotros mismos
y nos volvemos infelices totalmente una
contradicción por eso tenemos que pasar
de una felicidad hedónica basada en el
placer a una felicidad deuda y mónica
basada en la trascendencia ambas son
necesarias lo único que si desarrollamos
ese sentido vital será mucho más fácil
no estar en esa búsqueda insaciable de
ese placer externo
con todo lo mencionado hasta el momento
tenemos que empezar a adoptar el pasto
de la naturaleza cuyo secreto es la
partida hacia la calma la serenidad no
os voy a engañar la solución no es
rápida y requiere sacrificio palabra que
hoy en día no os gusta oír pero tenemos
vías de trabajo por un lado lo primero
es trabajar sobre nosotros mismos
conectar para ver cuáles son nuestras
necesidades que queremos y a su vez para
estar presentes frente a la ausencia
necesitamos presencia también presencia
social porque somos seres sociables y si
no queremos esa soledad en nuestra vida
tenemos que invertir tiempo para ello
vamos a tener que aprender a escuchar y
también a atender y atendernos el
mindfulness el yoga o la educación
emocional son estrategias que nos
permiten conectar gestionar nuestras
emociones y también gestionar los
conflictos tan típicos de la vida y
sobre todo si necesitamos ayuda pedirla
no pasa nada no somos peores personas ni
más débiles porque alguien nos ayude es
más si estamos vivos como especie es por
el trabajo grupal
os imaginais al hombre de cromagnon
quien va a cazar y diciendo no dejadme
solo ve a cazar yo
pues bueno igual ese día no volvía a la
cueva pero es que si todos hubieran
hecho lo mismo quizá yo no estaría hoy
aquí por tanto vamos a tener que
eliminar de nuestra cabeza esa sensación
de autosuficiencia que tenemos y
dejarnos ayudar y también ofrecer ayuda
no sólo podemos trabajar sobre nosotros
mismos sino que debemos tomar actitudes
en otros ámbitos por ejemplo la
alimentación elegir opciones de
alimentación local de temporada una
dieta saludable como la hacían nuestros
abuelos con muchos menos recursos que
ahora o los objetos que tengan el menor
impacto ambiental que sean sostenibles
de segunda mano
y comprar no desde la impulsividad sino
desde la necesidad y siento deciros pero
la lechera en forma de vaca que aparecen
todos los anuncios no es necesaria no lo
necesitáis
todo esto son vías para trabajar y dar
solución a los problemas pero hay
infinidad estos son pequeños gestos
por ello nuestro futuro es ahora ahora
es el momento de tomar las decisiones
para pasar de ese bienestar a corto
plazo a uno a medio y largo plazo vamos
a soñar a la grande porque no todo está
perdido porque tenemos lo más importante
que es nuestro poder de decisión y de
acción por eso hoy más que nunca nuestro
futuro es ahora muchas gracias
[Aplausos]